so far this year we've looked at three
topics two of them have been to do with
algebra and one student to do with
finance just want to help you remember
what those things are so we looked at am
one and am too those were our algebra
topics the first one was just the
general rules of solving equations
simplify expressions all those little
things which you actually have learnt in
previous years but we wanted to remember
them so that was am one algebraic
manipulation one algebraic manipulation
to we just finished actually and that
was when we looked at linear
relationships so things like straight
line graphs basically where you're
trying to solve those two simultaneously
like where do they intersect and also
funky things like peace waves draft like
we looked at step functions and once it
looked like this and you can see where
there's holes and things like that so we
looked at examples of that because those
are the kinds of relationships we've
seen in the real world for how different
quantities are related to each other and
how they grow just like how say the cost
that you spend on parking relates to the
amount of time that you spend there so
those are the two algebra topics then we
had a look as well as that and fm1 now
financial maths we know it's really
really practical we look just at dirty
money that's what everyone was talking
about earning money all the different
kinds of income that can be generated
whether they're to do with a job that
you have or an allowance but that the
government provides you
that's what if everyone was all about
ways that you can get money and we
finished just by looking at budgeting
like once you've got all that money what
do you do with it okay now we're gonna
move into fm2 now this is the last topic
before you're a p1 so it'll be included
and FF 2 is not about anybody it's about
investing it's about what happens when
you've got money and you want to be able
to use it what happens we can put it a
bake or you buy shares or all those
kinds of things
that's what investing is all about and
so this is not so much about like I've
got a job and therefore what it's coming
in this is more like I've already got
that money and what can I do with them
so the first concept that comes
underneath this we have met before
simple interest right now interest just
this simple idea is all about the fact
that
money we've said this before is about
power right like money is kind of
distilled power you work for it you have
it in your bank you know and then when
you give it to someone that it gives you
the power to ask them can you do this
job for me or this service and I will
exchange this money this distilled power
that I have earned interest for in
response for your product or service or
that kind of thing so interest is all
about the fact that if you are giving
that money that is still power to
someone else or they're giving it to you
which would be your getting a load then
you kind of have to pay for that right
or whoever you're giving money to has to
pay you for that right so that's all
simple interests that's what interest is
about as a concept so simple interest I
want you to remember is governed by this
very very simple formula if you remember
all the different pieces it's not that
complicated the eyelet starts with that
you begin with is the interest like how
much is somewhat going to pay you or are
you going to have to pay for the right
of being load money okay that's what the
interest is whether we're calculating
that P at the beginning stands for
principle even though it's spelled
exactly the same way as the person it
means something very different it's
talking about how much money do you
start with what's that amount that you
actually going to put into the bank
account or what's the amount of money
that you're going to be a load then
you've got these two parts over here all
right ed which stared for your interest
rate so that might be something like 5%
per annum or 0.1 percent per annum it
depends on where you're investing or
who's who's requested even payment from
you and lastly n stands for the number
of years you might also see this formula
written rather than I equals P R and
sometimes you'll see it written as I
equals P R T and the T stands for time
right so all a beat is what's the number
like how long are you giving your money
or borrowing this money from this other
person I should say even though it's
number of years that I've written here
it could just as easily be like months
or days or weeks those are much less
common but it's really the number of
time periods and when you have a look at
the question it will tell you in a lot
of detail you know okay how much is it
every six months three months what's a
week whatever it is it will be included
question what are the clues that you
will see like I said uses the most
common is if that rate that you get if
the interest rate is for instance they
might say 5% and they'll say PA which
means per atom at a be a year just like
you don't add you all right so if you
have a look at the interest rate that
often gives you a clue and then if you
read the wording of the question
carefully you'll be able to tell okay
well what's the type here in what time
scale we'll be working on is of days
weeks months years etc okay so now I'm
gonna walk you through four short
example questions that sort of unpack
how simple interest works and how we can
understand it and work with it say is
the first question this is as simple as
it gets
simple calculate the simple interest on
three hundred dollars again I'm gonna
encourage as much as possible just like
in an exam if you're trying to look at
the question understand what it means
it's in your interest you always say
okay look there's a key piece of
information there now I need to know I'm
gonna highlight it I'm gonna do that all
the way through and I'm gonna try and
describe what each piece is calculate is
simple interest on three hundred dollars
that's important at a flat rate I'll
talk about that in a second or six
percent per annum over three years okay
so I've got three critical pieces of
information they are going to describe
each of them in a minute but before I do
that I just want to highlight this when
it says flat rate flat rate is pretty
much acidity before simple interest in
other words for each year that you
ridden it's three years for itchy you're
in they'll keep up paying you the same
amount of money even though in fact your
money's gonna grow and grow and grow
that's the whole point of interest
they'll actually keep on paying you
that's a flat rate if you wanted to
think about it as a graph this is not a
trick question but how much interests
are they paid you over the number of
years and that interest is going to stay
the same in the first year as it is the
second year at the third year fourth
year all the way along so you can
literally see this graph which is the
kind of thing we're looking at last
topic it's a flat graph so that's why
it's called a flat rate okay so now that
we've got that out of the way let's just
finish off our sort of analysis of the
question by looking at these three
numbers and working out what each one is
well it says katka is simple interest
all over 300 dollars that they
that's your principle that's the
starting about okay the 6% per atom
that is the rate and three years that's
the number of time periods that are
interested so they've even given it to
you nice and in order so now I can solve
the question okay I'm always going to
begin by stating what my actual formula
is this formula is actually on your
formula sheet you don't get any marks by
writing down the formula but it means
that when you write the next step you
put the right numbers in the right spot
and that becomes really important the
more complicated the question becomes so
here because I've already identified
what PR Dead is supposed to be and I've
asked calculate the simple interest
which is this guy over here on the left
all I need to do is substitute him
appropriately which we had a look at in
our our algebra topic before
substitution is a key skill so I'm going
to put it by write others I've got three
hundred dollars here at the front I will
point out as well that here even though
I see that the rate is 6% okay I'm not
gonna write it as six percent even
though and we've talked about this in
class before and your calculator has a
percent button up there above the left
bracket okay I'm going to encourage you
not to do that but instead to get used
to to get into the rhythm of writing
your percentages as decimals okay so to
get six percent as a decimal you just
need to remember that percent means
dividing by a hundred per divide and set
as it like century 100 you know hundred
years so six percent literally means six
divided by a hundred that when you reach
for your calculator if you type in six
divided by 100 and press equals it might
just give you 6 divided by hundred if
that's the case it depends on how your
calculator is configured what kind of
calculator you have all you really need
to do is look for the SD button looks
like this there's an S double sided
arrow and a D and if you press that it's
going to convert your six over 100 which
is a fraction I actually will probably
give you 3 over 50 but we don't want
that we want it as a decimal if you
press your SD but it will hey drew 0.06
and that's the lab right actually
okay so YK back to my formula here I
wrote down by 300 which is principal
I've got my right here so 0.06 and then
lastly my neighbor if he is so good at
multiplied by three okay
that's all done I just need to go from
my calculator to crunch this the Brad
and I've got to go ahead and do that
there are three hundred by three that's
giving me $54 and that's it that's all
you're asked to do calculate the simple
interest so again when you're
highlighting things you want to be
really careful as to what they're
actually asking you it would just be as
it'll be just as easy to reframe this
question to say maybe what would be the
total value of what you have after three
years and that would be not just the 54
that maybe the bank has paid uses you've
been giving them um your buddy to loan
it with a 54 plus the 300 you started
with so if the question was calculate
the total value it would be three
hundred dollars and the 54 that you've
just sort of accrued as interest but
right now all they wants a simple
interest
so I've done I equals fifty four dollars
simple stuff